HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING AND1
DUE TO THE CONTENT CONTINUED
STAY AT HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING FISCAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY HELP
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. ROSS
REQUIRED MET THAT MASKS BE
WORN- AND PHYSICA DISTANCE IN
BE MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFY. WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR IN A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE YOU'RE NOT
HAVE AMASSED WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS PROTECT
WITNESS TESTIMONY FOR TODAY. IF
ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND I'LL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THAT'S THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING TO
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING WE
ARE USED TO ONE PERSON A TIME.
WILL ALSO BE A- FIRM DIALING
WITNESSES WILL USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE. THROUGH
WHICH ANY WHAT CONTEST. ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON HIS
BEGINNING THEIR PRESENTATION.
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED
ON. WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE A BILL IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCASTS AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. YOU HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE. PLEASE CALL
OR COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
SEVEN AND MY STAFF IS THERE TO
HELP I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE MAY
NEED TO LIMIT HOW LONG THE
PHONE LINES ARE OPEN FOR EACH
BILL SO WE ARE AS WE ARE TIED
ON A TIGHT HEARING SCHEDULE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE
HAVE TWO BILLS. TODAY MISTER-
MAIENSCHEIN IS GONNA BE
PRESENTING- AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
COUPLE OF WITNESSES AS WELL AS
YOU MENTIONED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
REPRESENTS AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO CONTAIN
SKYROCKETING HEALTH CARE COSTS
THIS COMMITTEE PASSED THIS BILL
LAST YEAR IS AB TWELVE FORTY
NINE. THE BILL WAS
UNFORTUNATELY VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR. THE LANGUAGE IN AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR REFLECTS
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT. EMPLOYERS TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE BENEFITS TO
THEIR EMPLOYEES STRUGGLE TO
CONTAIN COSTS AND OBTAIN THE
BEST QUALITY OF CARE. THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE TWO PILOTS ONE IN
THE SOUTHERN PORTION OF THE
STATE AND THE OTHER IN THE
NORTHERN SECTION THAT WOULD
OPERATE FOR A PERIOD OF FOUR
YEARS. THE PILOTS WOULD INCLUDE
RISK BEARING PROVIDERS THAT ARE
MONITORED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE FOR
FINANCIAL SOLVENCY AND
OPERATIONS. SELF FUNDED
EMPLOYER PLANS WOULD USE RISK
BASED OR CAPITATED PAYMENT
MECHANISMS WITH THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS FOR THEIR SERVICES
RATHER THAN PURE FEE FOR
SERVICE COMPENSATION. AT THE
END OF THE PERIOD THE
PARTICIPANTS WOULD REPORT ON
THE OUTCOMES OF THE TWO PILOTS.
TO INFORM THE LEGISLATURE ON
PROMISING MODELS OF HEALTHCARE
FINANCING AND DELIVERY A STUDY
BY THE UC. SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PREDICTED THAT THIS TYPE
OF MODEL COULD REDUCE HEALTH
CARE EXPENDITURES BY AN
ESTIMATED A HUNDRED AND TEN
BILLION DOLLARS OVER TEN YEARS.
COMBATING THE RISING COSTS OF
HEALTH CARE REQUIRES A NEW WAY
OF THINKING THE PILOT. PROJECTS
AUTHORIZED BY THIS BILL CAN
CHANGE THE WAY WE APPROACH
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY. AT TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS SCOTT
WATCH AND THEN ALSO I BELIEVE
ON THE PHONE LARGE JOSH. BEFORE
BEFORE WE LIVED. I HAVE ALLOW
YOUR TESTIMONY I DO APOLOGIZE-
IS SO MANY ACCESS CODES FLYING
AROUND HERE THESE DAYS THAT'S
WE- APPARENTLY. I GAVE SOME
INCORRECT INFORMATION SO MY
APOLOGIES. THE PUBLIC LINE THE
TELEPHONE NUMBER IS CORRECT
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
HOWEVER THE ACCESS CODE WAS NOT
CORRECT- SO. THIS IS THE ACCESS
CODE THAT I'M TOLD IS CORRECT.
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO.
ZERO TWO TWO. I'M HOPING THAT
SOMEONE THERE CAN VERIFY THAT
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S ON THE
SCREEN. GOOD OKAY SO ANYWAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE INTERRUPTION
MISTER WATCH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN A MEMBER SCOTT
WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL IN THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS PROBABLY. STE CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. YOU WELL
KNOW MISTER CHAIRMAN OF MY
UNION HEALTH AND WELFARE TRUST
FUNDS HAVE CONTRACTED DIRECTLY
WITH PHYSICIANS AND HOSPITALS.
SINCE THEIR EXISTENCE BEGAN YOU
KNOW FIFTY YEARS AGO THIS BILL
IN A PILOT PROGRAM ALLOWS US TO
CONTRACTOR ACTUALLY NOT FOR A
FEE FOR SERVICE AS WE DO TODAY
BUT ON A CAPITATED BASIS
RETURNING. SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS
BACK TO THE TRUST FUND AND TO
OUR MEMBERS THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE NEGOTIATED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OR IN THREE MAIN
CATEGORIES IN FOR YOUR SUNSET
AS OPPOSED TO A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET. ADDITIONAL ON BUDGET IN
OTHER PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE
THAT MEMBERS ARE FULLY INFORMED
OF ALL THE OPTIONS IN IT IN
THEIR DECISIONS IN CHOOSING A
PLAN. AND THEN THIRDLY
PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE THAT IF A
PROVIDER GROUP WERE TO GO
INSOLVENT. THEY WOULDN'T BE
THE- IT WOULDN'T BE THE MEMBER
THAT WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE BUT
THAT THE TRUST FUNDED ACTUALLY
BACK FILL. IN ENSURE THAT THE
MEMBER WAS PROTECTED WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS WE BELIEVE WE ARE ON
THE RIGHT PATH TO GET A
SIGNATURE AND WE WOULD URGE AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER WHICH- ALSO WE HAVE-
LARA JOSH IS THAT CORRECT VIVA.
SO BOB MOVED OUR MODERATOR MAY
OPEN THE LINE FOR THE- WHO WE
BE JOIN US BY TELEPHONE. SO OUT
THE MODERATE OPEN THE LINE FOR
LAURA LAURA JOSH. IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. OKAY GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU TWENTY MEMBERS YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING MORE JOSH
GENERAL MANAGER EXTERNAL CASH
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS WE THAT
WERE A PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
BABY ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY
SCHOOLS WE'VE UP PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS FOR
EDUCATION PUBLIC AGENT PEOPLE
ABOUT TRUST UNDER THE- REVENUE
CODE SECTION FIVE A ONE FIFTY
NINE. BY LAW ON THE BOOKS
AREN'T MEANT ONLY BE USED FOR
THE BENEFIT OF OUR TRUST
MEMBERS UNLIKE OTHER HEALTH
PLAN THERE'S NO ONE WHO PROFITS
IN THIS PLAN THERE'S NO
DISTRIBUTION OF EARNINGS. AND
THE ACCESS USERS MAY NOT BE
USED WITH ANYTHING BUT FOR THE
EMPLOYER IS NOT RETURNED TO BE
EMPLOYERS. EVEN GOVERNING BOARD
OF DIRECTORS REPRESENTS EQUAL
VOICES OF BOTH LABOR AND
MANAGEMENT WITH REPRESENTATION
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AND THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AS WELL AS OTHERS
ALONG WITH SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT COUNTY BUSINESS.
OUR MISSION IS SIMPLE IT IS TO
CONNECT A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS WITH THE
HIGHEST QUALITY AND MOST.
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE POSSIBLE.
BY TRUCK SOURCE. LIKE THE
OFFICE LOCATION ADVOCATE AND I.
ACOSTA THE ACT AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR WILL GIVE A THE ABILITY TO
DRAW CON. WITH THE- THAT
PROVIDE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ALLOW US TO
CREATE EFFECTIVE INTEGRATED AND
CONSUMER CENTRIC NETWORKS. WE
URGE THE PILOT NOW BUT THE
TIMING IS NEVER BEEN MORE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE NINETEEN
CRISIS IS TAKING A SIGNIFICANT
HELPFUL. ON BOTH THE PHYSICAL
AND EMOTIONAL HEALTH OF OUR
PUBLIC SECTOR AND EDUCATION
WORKERS. MAKING IT IMPERATIVE
WE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
AFFORDABLE ACCESS BOTH IN
PREMIUMS AS WELL AS OUT OF
POCKET EXPENSES BOTH MEDICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
BY GIVING OUR MEMBERS ACCESS TO
DEVELOPMENT BEST HEALTHCARE
POSSIBLE WE CAN ENSURE OUR
WORKFORCE REMAINS READY AND
ABLE TO SERVE THE PUBLIC GOOD.
NOT ONLY THAT WE PROJECT THE
POTENTIAL SAVINGS BOOK
PARTICIPATING EMPLOYERS AND
UNIONS IN THE BACK TO BE IN
EXCESS OF ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
BOTH TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN THE IN THE ROOM
HERE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL JUST YOUR
NAME AND POSITION ONLY PLEASE.
MY NAME. YOUR NAME AND POSITION
ONLY AND IF YOU IS IN A. IS
THIS MICROPHONE ON YOUR NAME A
POSITION ONLY THE MICROPHONES
ON. MY NAME IS NINE THOUSAND
DEATHS THAT'S IT THE CDC
ADJUSTED THE NUMBERS THANK YOU
ARE YOU SPOKE THE STATE THANK
YOU I THINK THAT THAT TEST WAS
NOT APPROPRIATE THAT WE'RE TO
SPEAKING ABOUT IS. TELLING
CALIFORNIA. YEAH NOT. THANK YOU.
YEAH IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO SIT
DOWN OR TO EXIT THE BUILDING.
YEAH YEAH AND I LIKE THIS. ONE
ON THE ANYONE IS THERE ANY- OUR
MODERATORS OR ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND PATCH THEM
THROUGH. THANK YOU ARE YOU
AREN'T A PART OF AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO A
LINE OF A NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE MOMENT THANK YOU YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NINE NINETEEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SARA
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GIVE THEIR LINE NUMBER.
ANEXO HOTEL LINE NUMBER OF
TWENTY ONE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BILL BARCELONA
FROM THE AMERICAN PHYSICIAN
GROUPS CO SPONSORED AND
SUPPORTED THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER PARTICIPANTS IN Q.
THANK YOU- I BELIEVE WE HAVE-
MR WE HAVE A OPPOSITION ON THE
TELEPHONE. MISTER LEWIS US.
YEAH YEAH GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR- THIS IS NICK LEAVES US
WITH A CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH PLANS- THANK YOU-
THANK A CAP AS OPPOSED TO
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR- THE
ARRANGEMENT THE RANGE MEANS
AUTHORIZED UNDER THIS BILL-
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE ESTABLISH
UNFAIR COMPETITIVE PLAYING
FIELD BETWEEN ENTITIES UNDER
RESTRICTED LICENSURE AND OUR
MEMBER HEALTH PLANS- THIS BILL
ALLOWS RESTRICTED LICENSE USED
TO ACT LIKE HEALTH PLANS BUT
WITHOUT MANY OF THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS ARE FULLY LICENSED
PLANS- FOR SOLVENCY AND OTHER
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS- WELL THE
PROVIDER ENTITIES CONTEMPLATED
UNDER THESE PROGRAMS CURRENTLY
DO COMPLY. WITH SOME FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY REQUIREMENTS THOSE
OBLIGATIONS ARE NOT AS HIGH AS
THOSE FOR FULLY LICENSED PLANS-
IN CURRENT STANDARDS HAVE
PRIMARILY BEEN PUT IN PLACE
BECAUSE OF A HISTORY OF
INSOLVENCIES- GENERALLY
SPEAKING WITHOUT A HEALTH PLAN
SPONSOR INVOLVED IN THESE TYPES
OF ARRANGEMENTS WELL WE COULD
PLEASE CONSUMERS IN THE STATE
OF AMBIGUITY RICK IN REGARDS TO
THEIR COVERAGE- THIS IS A
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR BILL WAS
DEBATED IN VETO LAST YEAR AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY AND WE
FAILED TO UNDERSTAND WHY THIS
BILL IS SO NECESSARY NOW. IN
THE MIDST OF A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ANY EXISTENCE OF-
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE REGULATIONS ON THE MATTER
SO FOR THOSE. REASONS WE DO
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. SIR NGUYEN
IN ISRAEL IN TH CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. LET'S
SAY I TAKE ON. HIS TESTIMONY
WAS GIVEN ME YES NAME INTO ONLY
SHOULD YOU DECIDE THAT YOU WANT
TO VERY FROM THAT WILL JUST
CLOSE YOUR MICROPHONE OFF
SIMPLE AS THAT. NAME A POSITION
ON THE BILL. ON THE BILL. NOT
ON ANYTHING ELSE ON THE BILL
WHAT IS YOUR POSITION AND THE
NAME ON THE BILL. MY NAME IS
OPEN THE STATE. THANK YOU. WE
DO HAVE RULES WE DO HAVE
DECORUM AND I'M BEING VERY
FRIENDLY VERY PATIENT WHEN WE
ASK FOR POSITION ON A BILL WE
ASK FOR POSITION. ON A BILL.
I'M NOT SIX. YEAH ALL RIGHT I
AM FOLLOWING THE RULES THAT WE
ESTABLISHED IN OUR HOUSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SECRETARY
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE YOU TAKE THE ROLE
PLEASE WHAT HERE WHAT HERE
MAYES MAYES HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
YEAH AGUIAR-CURRY HERE BIGELOW
BIGELOW HERE BONTA. BURKE
CARILLO CARILLO HERE FLORA
FLORA HERE LET ALONE. CARTY
NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS HERE
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HERE WALDRON. WE HAVE A CORE.
YES OF COURSE SO BRING BILL
NEED TO SEE ON THE PHONE THINK
OF A MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION.
SECOND THERE- MADAM MADAM
MODERATORS OR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE TELEPHONE I'M
SORRY I GOT A LITTLE
DISTRACTED. THANK YOU. IF YOU
WERE IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
TWO FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE A LINE
THIRTEEN. THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING LITERATURE
AND NUMBER EIGHT FORGET ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWER
AUTHORITY RESPECT IDEA HUMAN
OUT THERE A POST AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND I'M SORRY I MISSPOKE IT AB.
ONE ONE TWO FOUR FOR OPPOSITION.
YOU MAY PRESS. ONE ZERO. YOUR
CARE WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. IN SAYING NINE AND
WE HAVE A MOTION PRIMUS
AGUIAR-CURRY DID I HEAR A
SECOND. BUT BY THIS CARILLO
CELL MOTION IS- TO PASS TO THE
FLOOR I GUESS. AB ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR MOTION IS CONCURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENTS WOULD I WOULD
I'D MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING
BONTA BONTA I BURKE CARRILLO
CARILLO ICE LAURA. LAURA HI
LIMóN MCCARTY NAZARIAN RAMOS
RAMOS I'D RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I WALDRON. SEVEN EYES
ZERONOS LEAVE THE- THE BILL ON
CALL AND- ASKED MEMBERS- IN THE
BUILDING TO PLEASE COME TO THE
COMMITTEE HEARING WE HAVE ONE
MORE BILL THANK YOU MISTER
CHANNELS MISTER MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN OUR NEXT BILL IS AB
THIRTEEN STE TWENTY SEVEN BY
MISS BETWEEN NORRIS. KRISTIN WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES. I ASSUME
THESE ARE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT JUDGING FROM MY NOTES SO-
WHENEVER WHENEVER YOU'D LIKE TO
GO AHEAD YOU'RE WELCOME TO
WELCOME PRESIDENT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB I
ONE THREE TWO SEVEN. EIGHTY ONE
THREE TWO SEVEN WILL
RATIONALIZE AS THE CALCULATION
FOR MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR LABORATORY SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M THIS PROTECTS
CALIFORNIA JOBS AND- ALSO
PROTECTS CALIFORNIA'S LAB
CAPACITY WHICH IS PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL IN THE MIDST OF OUR
CURRENT CRISIS- WITH THAT I
WOULD LOVE TO. HEAR FROM THE
WITNESSES THAT WE HAVE ON THE
PHONE WE'VE GOT CHRISTY FLY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CLINICAL
LAB ASSOCIATION AND MOLLY
ROBSON FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD
THE SUPPORT GROUP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A META MODERATOR IF
YOU'D OPEN THE WITNESS LINE.
AND ALLOW THE WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY. HI GOOD MORNING THIS
IS CHRISTY BOY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL LABORATORY
AT THAT THE ASIAN. AND WE ARE
ONE OF THE CO SPONSOR OF AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THIS BILL
PROTECTS THE MEDIC HOW GREAT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. HAVE CAREFULLY
CALCULATED USING CALIFORNIA
MARKET DATA. THIS IS NOT A RATE
INCREASE IT WILL KEEP RATES THE
SAME. AND IT DOES PROTECT OUR
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL LABORATORY
RATE FROM BEING CHANGED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR AND DURING THE LAST
YEAR. LABORATORIES AROUND
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK TO EXPAND
TESTING FOR ECHO THE NINETEEN.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WELL
HEALTH IS A CRITICAL LABORATORY
PLANNED FOR NEXT YEAR AND PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE AS THEY CONTINUE
TO HELP INCREASE TESTING SO
THAT WE CAN GET GOAL TO RE OPEN
AND WE GET READY FOR THE
UPCOMING. SEASON FOR ALL THESE
REASONS. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THE FEAR I FELT AND I
AM AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS TODAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN OUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MORNING HEARING
MEMBERS. THAT SAID MOLLY ROBSON
WITH. HEALTH REPRESENTING OUR
TECHNICAL WHO OPERATE THE STATE.
ADDRESS MENTIONED THE MEDICARE
CAP ON REIMBURSED RATE THE
CONCERNING AS IT IS MUCH SLOWER
THAN THE MARKET BASED RATE FOR
CALIFORNIA. UNFORTUNATELY A
FACT FROM LIKE PARENTHOOD WHERE
A FIVE PER OF OUR PATIENTS BASE.
ONE MEDIC HAL AT OUR HEALTH
CENTERS WE PROVIDE MILLION THE
LABORATORY TASK VERY VARIETY OF
SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
CONCERNS. SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT GIVEN THE ON GOING
AFTER I CRISIS IN THE STATE ARE
THE LAPTOPS WE DO FOR GONORRHEA.
SYPHILIS ANYTIME. GIVEN 85% OF
OUR PATIENTS MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES THIS CAPTAIN BACK
ON OUR CLINICAL LAB
REIMBURSEMENT. AND ASKED ME TO
CALL HER KELLY IT'S ABOUT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY ON TOP
OF ONLINE MEDICAL CLAWBACKS AND
RATE REDUCTIONS ON TRADITIONAL
SERVICES. PICKING UP RIDERS
CANNOT AFFORD THESE GREAT
LOSSES AS WE DO NOT HAVE OTHER
PAYER MIX BETWEEN ON. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN ENTERED
MEDICAL LAB RIGHT OR NOT
PROJECT TO ADDITIONAL CUTS DOWN
MARKET VALUE. AND ALLOW PEAK
YOU KNOW PROVIDERS LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING CRITICAL CARE TO
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES. BELIEVE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY AFTER I
NOT ONLY BE THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
CHAMBER HERE WHO ARE IN THE
MEETING ROOM. THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
C. ONE MADAM. CAN WE GO TO
OPPOSITE. IS OR ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE. FOR OPPOSITION.
PROPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE CARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
C. NINE WE HAD A MOTION FROM
AND I FORGOTTEN ALREADY. MISTER
MISTER BIGELOW- SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO THE MOTION IS THE
CURRENT CURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS- THEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB THIRTY
TWENTY SEVEN CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS THAT FIRST REFERRED
TO ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WOULD I WOULD I'D
MAYES. MAYES AYE AYE GEAR CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW II BONTA BONTA AYE
BURKE CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA
FLORA I LIVE ALONE MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS I'D
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
WALDRON. NINE EYES ZERO NO BILL
PASSES PASSES THANK YOU
MANAGEMENT AGENCY GENEROUS AND
KIND AND WE- WE STILL HAVE A
BILL ON CALL THAT ACTUALLY ARE
COMPLETED THE REST OF OUR
AGENDA SO. I THINK IF YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO STAY HERE AND-
HANG OUT IF YOU WANT. FOUR
NINE. YEAH EVERYBODY. OKAY.
OKAY THE. YOU KNOW. YEAH YEAH.
THAT'S. THIS. MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE THE WRONG CALL THE
MEMBERS ON A ALTHOUGH TWENTY
FOUR. BURKE LIMóN. MCCARTY HAS
AREA RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ. WELL
EIGHT ICE THE BILL IS OUT
PLEASE- OPEN THE ROLE AND CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN BURKE
LIMóN MCCARTY NAZARIAN
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I WALDRON.
TEN ICE. THE ECHO THANK YOU
MISTER REGUS. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR A
COUPLE MORE MINUTES.
AND YEAH.
WELL. OKAY. OR OR.
RIGHT NOW.
YEAH. OR.
AND SECRETARY HAVE
YOU OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. BURKE LIMóN
MCCARTY NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE
WALDRON. NINE ICE THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY- WELL OPEN THE
ROLE ON A THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
BURKE LIMóN MCCARTY NAZARIAN
AYE NAZARIAN AYE WALDRON.
ELEVEN I THINK YOU. THAT'S IT.
ALL. THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS
THANK YOU WE'LL WAIT A COUPLE
MORE MINUTES SOME. IN THE
TERMINAL CARE OKAY I MEAN
LITTLE OR YEAH. YEAH I THINK IT
WILL WAIT ANOTHER COUPLE
MINUTES BUT.
WELL SIXTY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE- AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON A B. ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. BURKE LEMOND.
LIMóN NIGHT MCCARTY. WALDRON
TEN ICE THE LEVIN IS IN A. TEN
IS TEN OKAY MY APOLOGIES IN AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. BURKE
LIMóN HI LIMóN I AM MCCARTY
THERE'S THERE WALDRON TWELVE
I'D- THAT WAS IT OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY I
THINK WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND- CLOSE THE HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE THANK
YOU.